[Música]
me levanto mis pies descalzos tocan el
piso frío de mi cuarto
siempre odie dormir con medias me hacía
sentir atrapada
manejo hacia el gimnasio y aprovecho una
luz roja para subir una historia para
instagram para mí es depresión para los
demás es compromiso o tal vez disciplina
con una vida saludable
40 minutos de corredor a una rutina
fortísima de piernas y un playlist que
me haga cantar para por lo menos evitar
pensar esas dos horas suenan las siete y
media y debo regresar a casa
y mientras que me ducho las lunas se
empañan y las lágrimas se confunden con
el agua que corre por mi espalda sé que
serán uno de esos días les cuelgo mi
casaca gris
a la quien secreto y amo mi casaca de la
tristeza y es que cada vez que me siento
incapaz de dar un paso fuera de casa
este simple pedazo de tela es lo
suficientemente como y absorbente para
poder pasar todo un día en el trabajo
llorando pero sin que nadie se dé cuenta
es a gabriela trabajaba en una de las
empresas más importantes de tecnología
del país
dirigía la estrategia digital de una de
las marcas más importantes de la
compañía
un puesto que estaba lleno de tareas que
ya no entendía pero que se rompía el
lomo por completar
eventos excel es capacitación es algo
normal
sin embargo todos sus esfuerzos nunca
parecían ser suficientes
si le hubieran preguntado
a esa gabriela quién era se hubiera
desmoronado
antes de esbozar un tímido no sé
gabriela renuncia es fácil no te
detengas pero no no era fácil para esa
gabriela
no es fácil darle la espalda a la
primera gran compañía que te daba una
oportunidad
no es fácil dejar de lado un salario que
alimenta a tu familia no es fácil
entender que simplemente no encaja
entonces no
renunciar nunca fue una opción
y es que ella sí que lo intentó
cada vez que veía un poco de luz dado un
par de golpes ahogados para salir salía
a comprar
papelógrafos plumones post-its y se
disponía a intentar una nueva
metodología de orden para darle otra
oportunidad a ese trabajo
lo hizo ocho veces a la octava vez ya no
tenía fuerzas para seguir nadando hacia
la superficie
y esque
la autoexigencia puede hacerte
sobresalir pero también puede hundirte
es a gabriela prefería mantener una
rutina
repetitiva y agobiante antes de
enfrentarse a lo desconocido a lo que
más le daba miedo y la paralizada
al miedo a fracasar
al miedo de no poder sustentar a su
familia
al miedo de quedarse atrás
al miedo de no ser suficiente
ahora probablemente estén pensando quién
es ella por qué está aquí qué rayos está
haciendo dando de ex si solamente nos ha
hablado de su depresión o de sus peores
miedos
mi nombre es habla de negro y soy una
emprendedora internacional actualmente
dirijo una consultora que ayuda a
empoderar a profesionales y
emprendedores a compartir sus ideas
expertise y conocimientos lo que
buscamos hacer es democratizar todo este
conocimiento cultivado y pueda llegar a
la persona que lo necesite como no estar
orgullosa en menos de un año crecimos de
2 a 20 colaboradores y hoy atendemos a
más de 80 clientes de nivel gerencial de
las empresas con más renombre en
latinoamérica
y si suena genial
pero nada de esto hubiera pasado
si yo no me hubiera enfrentado a mis
miedos si yo no hubiera tocado fondo'
y es que yo creo que no hay personas
brillantes sin espacios oscuros
mi motor de vida es y siempre será el
conocimiento
una de las cosas que me mantuvo a flote
en ese etapa gris fueron las personas
conocí gente
extraordinaria gente muy inspiradora
realmente gente brillante
y lo que más me molestaba era que era
totalmente injusto toda esa luz se
quedaba atrapada en las cuatro paredes
de su oficina no tenía el alcance que
realmente necesitaba
así como ellos me ayudaron a mí yo quise
ayudarlos a ellos
construir un puente entre esas
cultivadas mentes hacia el mundo
exterior
me convertí en el canal que ellos
necesitaban que des a mi trabajo ellos
podrían brillar más alto y alumbrar a
más personas había encontrado nuevamente
mi motivo aún seguía trabajando en
corporación pero las ganas de rendirme
eran cada vez menores
después de tres meses logré la inversión
inicial y un 15 de diciembre del 2019
era libre
pero no estaba preparada para lo que
venía
después de un mes de arduo trabajo
conseguimos siete clientes
pero necesitábamos 20
mi emprendimiento parecía un total
fracaso y cuando menos lo esperaba llegó
la pandemia
los profesionales
dejaron de existir en el mundo físico
las conversaciones de pasillo los
almuerzos con el jefe todo dejó de
existir
la única forma de que estas personas
vuelvan a la normalidad
era en el mundo digital
y es ahí donde yo vi mi oportunidad
enfocamos los mensajes en la empresa a
lo que realmente importa al verdadero y
yo de los profesionales y empezamos a
hablar acerca de reputación digital
mucha gente se confunde cuando hablo de
este término pero por ello les voy a dar
una definición súper sencilla
la reputación digital no es más que un
comportamiento repetitivo en el tiempo
que busca calar en la memoria digital
del colectivo en otras palabras lo que
buscamos es coreografiar este verdadero
yo de los profesionales y mostrarlo en
el mundo online
en menos de un mes
triplicamos las ventas y es que las
personas realmente necesitaban ayuda
para poder trasladar su identidad a las
plataformas sociales
necesitaban saber quiénes eran que
querían o que les inspiraban preguntas
tan simples pero que nunca se habían
detenido a responder
y es que solemos ir por la vida como
caballitos de carrera
fluimos por las oportunidades pero no
sabemos que podemos decidir cuáles
escoger
hoy yo puedo responder a las preguntas
que más me aterraban
quién soy soy una emprendedora
empedernida mi pasión está en la ayuda
social sobre todo si quiero ayudar a las
personas a que hagan brillar más alto su
luz que quiero
empoderar a más personas a compartir lo
que son y lo que saben
que me mueve
el conocimiento
busco democratizar este conocimiento tan
cultivado para que pueda llegar a la
persona que lo necesite
ese espacio oscuro de mi vida fue lo que
me trajo aquí y aunque me haya caído más
de una vez la perseverancia me hizo
inquebrantable
si tú estás en el fondo hoy
recuerda que la luz también puede ser tu
tu alma alumbra